there is a cost to us as a news
organization to knowingly broadcast
untrue things we are here to bring you
the news it hurts our ability to do that
if we live broadcast what we fully
expect in advance to be a Litany of lies
and false accusations no matter who says
them instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus stops with
every vaccinated person we take our
responsibilities seriously a vaccinated
person gets exposed to the virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else we revisit decisions like
this all the time it cannot use a
vaccinated person as a host to go get
more people we make the best call that
we can in real time every time that
means
the vaccines will get us to
the end of this
foreign
people I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's June 15 2023 that's right
people we are halfway through pride
month and if your genitals have not been
chemically castrated forcibly by the
United States government yet you're in
pretty good shape so happy to have you
here uh I'd like to once again thank
Rachel Maddow that was a little edit
that we put together after yesterday's
show I'd like to thank Rachel Maddow and
all of the quote-unquote journalists of
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC for making my job so easy all I
had to do was say hey
Connor could you put that together
and then next thing you know it's like
it's just so easy these frauds these
buffoons these character character
actors these larpers pretending they're
journalists
but here you are at the Reuben report
where we do something different uh as
you know guys we are live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and locals if you haven't
subscribed on Rumble yet that is the
future of the internet did you see what
happened on Rumble yesterday actually uh
so Andrew Tate you guys know Andrew Tate
we actually played a video of Andrew
totally coincidentally yesterday Andrew
Tate did a live stream on Rumble
yesterday it had at one point over 450
000 concurrent live stream views like
like that is like absolutely
unbelievable the the rumble
infrastructure held up we don't use
Amazon AWS which is basically running
every website on the internet we are
running our own cloud servers through
Rumble that Rumble owns and it's going
to be uh launched uh sort of
business-wide probably uh by early next
year so that was a nice Monumental
moment for us uh and speaking of
monumental moments I have a quick
announcement for those of you who'd like
to join us in the
reubenreport.locals.com community
we are doing some house cleaning here as
we get to the summer and uh we've got
some T-shirts and other merch that we're
clearing out because we are relaunching
our new store in the next couple days
with some new items so here's what we're
doing for you fine people if you join
the Reuben report locals Community from
now Thursday until Sunday night not only
do you if you do it annually you have to
join annually not month by month if you
join annually first off you get two
months for free and we will also send
you a Reuben report t-shirt we have
various types of t-shirts we have the
standard Reuben report t-shirt we've got
hoodies we've got all sorts of stuff but
we've got the standard Ruben report
t-shirt we're going to send you one of
those we've got we've got a whole bunch
of different stuff we don't know what
you're gonna we did a live show in Miami
uh not too long ago and we have a couple
of these left over one lucky person if
you sign up annually
you get the T-shirt oh and by the way if
you're a current local subscriber so if
you're a monthly local subscriber and
you go to annual you're also in on this
you're going to get the stuff too we
will have an announcement for our
current annual subscribers tomorrow
don't worry you guys aren't being left
out you're getting some extra access and
extra discounts when it comes to some of
the new stuff we're releasing
but because I'm a big fan of Willy Wonka
and his delicious chocolates we thought
we would do something like a Golden
Ticket involved in all this so one
person
who signs up annually or is the current
local monthly subscriber who turns into
an annual subscriber
we'll get this hat now this hat I'm
going to sign this Reuben report hat
right now
okay using a silver Sharpie the rarest
of all Sharpies
all right
I have signed it
there you go Dave Rubin you will get
this hat and you will get free tickets
to a live Reuben report event when we
start launching some new ones in the
fall so okay one more time and then
we'll get to the show if you're a new
local subscriber or if you're a current
monthly subscriber jump over to annual
get your two months free you get some
merchandise you might get the hat and
the tickets and then once you subscribe
all you have to do is email uh support
reubenreport.com from the email address
you signed up with we'll send you the
merch you get your free months you get
early access to stuff you get add free
stuff and all the other bonuses that the
people and locals get you get to chat
with us ask us extra questions and
everything else how'd I do on that guys
for promotional purposes we did okay all
right very good do I have to put any uh
asterisks or none of it's going to make
you have diarrhea or vomiting or
restless leg syndrome or anything else
as far as I know as for the show today
actually we are doing a
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a so
if you sign up right now maybe you can
get a question in by the end of today's
show but I wanted to start with a little
more of just like the General State of
craziness because yes we are 15 days
into pride month the trans stuff seems
like it's completely out of control but
as I've been saying lately it does seem
like we're finally getting more and more
pushback we're getting more and more
boycotts more and more people are being
exposed as the ridiculous propagandists
they are and some of the companies are
starting to realize maybe this stuff
doesn't really work uh however there is
a place it's about 3 000 miles that way
uh called California it was once the
promise of America it was once the great
idea of the Western frontier that you
would go to and it was the biggest not
only geographically beautiful but it was
the greatest place to make a middle
class life really find the American
dream and prosper and it worked for
decade after decade after decade then
this guy Gavin Newsom became the
governor and now people are fleeing
California in droves for the last three
years for the first time ever California
has had a net loss of population and
Gavin Newsom is the governor and as you
guys know was also the former mayor of
San Francisco and I certainly don't have
to go into what has happened in San
Francisco but there is light at the end
of the tunnel because people are turning
this stuff around doing the boycotts
waking up so there's good stuff
happening parents are pushing back all
of that so we're going to get to all of
that after I talk to you about Birch
gold guys you know Congress once again
allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and the further devaluation of
the dollar as our national debt
continues to Skyrocket how are you
protecting your savings Times Like These
are a great reminder to diversify a
portion of your savings into gold and
you can do that with the help of Birch
gold and here's the easiest way to do it
Birch gold will help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
you don't pay a penny out of pocket as
bricks Brazil Russia India China and
South Africa band together against the
dollar more and more central banks are
crucifying you know what they're buying
yeah gold follow their lead visit
birchgold.com day for your free info kit
on gold there's no obligation just
information with an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau and thousands
of happy customers Birch gold can help
protect your savings too visit
birchgold.com Dave today
birchgold.com Dave okay so let's talk
about the trans lunacy in California
because that is the epicenter of the
craziness uh there was a hearing on uh
Phoenix can you scroll back for me what
was the exact time I want to get the
hearing totally correct there was a
hearing on youth gender Transitions and
Medicine a congressional hearing uh
there is a Woman by the name of Dr
Meredith McNamara she's an assistant
professor of pediatrics pediatrics at
the Yale School of Medicine here is
Congressman Dan Crenshaw friend of the
show congressman from Texas uh asking
her a bit about
some of their methodology some of the
science behind these transitions
especially when it comes to kids her
answer is quite shocking
you've said that we've cherry-picked
data how do you mean by how do you mean
that
so it is very unscientific and flawed to
pick a single study or a single
statistic and to discuss it in isolation
um totally agree medical experts are
able to talk about all the evidence as a
whole totally agree so it's good to look
at systematic reviews right that's the
gold standard of evidence when you're
trying to understand whether something
works or whether it doesn't so the
British Journal of Medicine looked at 61
systematic reviews with the conclusion
the quote there is great uncertainty
about the effects of puberty blockers
cross-sex hormones and surgeries of
young people Journal of endocrine
Society came up with the same conclusion
even the American Academy of Pediatrics
I'll cite the lack of evidence so here's
the thing if you're doing a therapy and
it's you know temporary whatever fine
maybe let's try it let's see if it works
but when you're talking about permanent
physiological changes do you not agree
just from an ethical standpoint that you
might want extremely strong evidence of
the benefits and there is no systematic
review that that states that there is
strong evidence of benefit
sir are you aware of how the quality
evidence grading system works and how
it's applied yeah yeah we've read
through it that's why I'm citing these
journals so which Journal says something
different we should have that debate
tell me a journal that has done
systematic reviews that cites different
evidence it cites strong evidence for
benefits of these therapies the
standards of care were developed based
on extensive you're not telling me any
Journal you're not telling me any study
don't say anything I would care yeah so
um only one
the standards of care that's the
standards of care that's that's that's
not a journal that's not a study that's
not an organization it's not an
institution you're just saying words
name one study
yeah I'm out of time I mean he did a
great job there that's what we ask out
of our Congress people right like know
what you're talking about it's it's way
too often we go to these Congressional
hearings and we see video out of the
stuff and they don't know what they're
talking about whether it's big Tech
whether it's gender stuff coveted stuff
whatever else he's saying show me a
study that proves we should be doing
this to kids show me some evidence she
keeps saying standards of care standards
of care is is a phrase as he says it's
just words it's just a phrase that
people use oh these should be the
standards of care we have if a
seven-year-old comes in and says she's a
boy we better do something that's our
standards of care but that's not
evidence that is not statistical
evidence meaning that there have been
studies scientific studies over time
that show that if you have these gender
transition these people come out
happier on the other side more fulfilled
not with all sorts of physical and
mental problems less suicidal etc etc so
he really just nailed her uh so that's
let's do a little uh here's one way we
can do it and here's another way we can
do it here on the Reuben report today so
that's Dan Crenshaw doing it the right
way now I would like you to listen to
our transportation secretary Pete budage
now Pete bootage edge of course as you
know had no zero zip qualifications to
become transfer transfer Transportation
secretary excuse me
he had no qualifications but the day
before super Tuesday as many of you
remember the Monday before super Tuesday
Monday's the day before Tuesday that
when the Democrats cut all the deals so
that they would get out of the way so
that Biden could be the nominee Pete was
promised something now I don't know that
he was promised Transportation secretary
that day but they basically said to him
you get out and you're gonna get
something they gave him Transportation
secretary so here he is doing a round
table for the folks for the
quote-unquote journalists at Time
Magazine and listen to the way he frames
what's going on in society today you'll
see how this is connected to the trance
though
I think it's safe
especially right now when you have one
side that has a maximalist commitment to
tearing down every Norm uh and uh and
law they don't like
so where does that put us and by the way
why does it happen
I think it's happening because there are
some people who find it easier
to
pick on really vulnerable young people
than to explain why they voted no on
money for roads and bridges
like the perfect
ridiculous shell game answer that
Democrats do with everything first off
this line one side has a maximalist
commitment to tearing down everything uh
you mean like tearing down gender like
tearing down our border like tearing
down every known way we've looked at
monetary policy forever
etc
etc are you talking about the Democrats
I think if you are talking about the
Democrats you might be on to something
but of course Pete's not talking about
the Democrats he's trying to pretend
that the Republicans are passing scary
bills to come after trans people and
might I remind you there is not one bill
in the United States in any state that
stops an adult trans person from living
any way that they wish to live wearing
whatever they want being called whatever
they want calling themselves whatever
they want getting into whatever
relationship they might want to get into
that any other consenting adult is
allowed to get into but he says these
things and then he sits around a group
of what I assume are DC or New York you
know liberal lefties who just sit there
and oh my God look at Pete he can put a
couple words together isn't he good
isn't he good so all right we showed you
what's happening in DC we showed you
what's happening I assume Time magazine
that was probably in New York maybe it
was in DC as well the Congressional
hearing was obviously in DC but where is
the true Bastion of craziness these days
where is the epicenter of lunacy yes it
is California and check this out this is
a local news report and at a school in
California school officials are freaking
out because they wanted to have a pride
day where everyone was gonna have to
wear pride shirts and there were going
to be Pride Flags I don't know what this
has to do with being in school or
anything else or white state workers
feel that they should be talking to kids
about sex and genitals and all that
stuff but the kids the kids themselves a
certain percentage of the kids did not
want to do it and they protested and now
the teachers in the administration are
freaking out and it made the local news
displays of intolerance and homophobia
are unacceptable this type of intolerant
rhetoric starts in the home parents
angry at Town Hall over intolerance at
Marshall Simons Middle School kids were
asked to wear Rainbow clothes in honor
of Pride Spirit day but some organized a
counter protest wearing red white and
blue or black the principal sharing a
statement to families that Pride posters
were ripped down stickers ripped up some
students chanted USA are my pronouns and
students showing Pride were intimidated
it was an unruly disruption in fact that
was organized ahead of time while some
parents were upset others say it was
overblown some of the kids threw the
stickers on the ground but you know I
can only speak for my daughter she just
she didn't want to wear that to school
it's not that she wanted to hurt
anybody's feelings she says her daughter
felt coerced to participate in the pride
event and was offended by some of the
messages like this quote from Tennessee
Williams human heart cannot be
straighted as curves and wines and my
daughter just kind of said you know Mom
that's that's offensive to to me who I
am good for that mother good for that
daughter the mother will probably be
considered a white supremacist soon
enough and have Los Angeles or
California it's not Los Angeles uh we'll
have California state officials at their
doorstep looking into their taxes and
everything else but all some of these
kids some of these kids took the took
the freaking stickers off that's all and
now it's hate and they're bigots and
everything else well you know what else
is going on in Cali we referenced this
the other day they have been pushing
through this bill which now has passed
this is this is so absolutely insane
that I actually cannot believe it's
happening like you know we talk about
politics all the time and crazy things
happen and obviously the culture wars
just like endless craziness all the time
right but this one is so nuts that I
actually cannot believe it's happening
in America although I guess maybe it's
not happening in America it's happening
in California which is a whole other
thing what they are doing in California
is we showed you some of the video
Yesterday by the sponsor of the bill who
happens to have a trans daughter if your
seven-year-old child comes home
and says that they are a girl even
though they are a boy if you do not
affirm that for them whatever your
seven-year-old child thinks the state
can now come and take your child away
from you child services can come and now
say your child is not yours in essence
you are abusing your child they will put
that child in some sort of State
Facility or give them to some other
group of people who will literally
chemically castrate them force them to
undergo drugs and procedures and all of
that stuff that is happening in
California right now here is a guy by
the name of California Senator Scott
Wilk he's been a state senator there for
at least a decade and he actually is
sane he has had it and listened to his
message
I'm now in year 11 in in the state
legislature and all the time we're
proposing policies to protect children
well after 11 years I've come to a
conclusion that we need to start
protecting parents that's just not
happening I've been here with a
witnessed a full frontal assault on
Charter Schools taking away parents uh
choice and how their children are going
to be educated to the detriment
particularly of children of color
in recent years we have put government
bureaucrats between parents children and
doctors when it comes to medical care
and now we have this where if a parent
does not support the ideology of the
government they're going to be taken
away from the home now I agree with both
Senator weiner Senator Laird that today
it only involves divorce proceedings and
frankly a judge can already factor
factor this in but I can assure you it's
not going to end with divorce
proceedings in the past when we've had
these discussions and I've seen parental
rights
um atrophied I've I've incur I've
encouraged people to keep fighting I've
changed my mind on that if you love your
children you need to flee California you
need to flee and it just breaks my heart
born and raised in this state I love
this state I'm not going to stay in this
state because it's it's just too
oppressive and I believe in Freedom and
so I'm going to move to America when I
leave the legislature I'm going to move
to America I bet you this guy ends up in
Florida and we would be happy to have
you here so this has now happened in
California you really must understand
this it is on the way it is happening if
you are watching this show and you're in
California and you I don't even have to
say if you're conservative if you're a
roughly sane person and you are sending
your kid to public school or wherever
else if one day that child's mind is
infected and they come home and say this
know that
you live in a place where they can take
your child away if that is not enough to
get you moving I don't know what is I
genuinely do not know what is but they
are it is now State sanctioned
kidnapping in California these people
are completely out of control but the
thing is there is no bottom to this
bottomless pit
it ends never it goes and goes and goes
and it's our job not to follow those
people into that endless pit right
because it's not just the gender stuff
the other part of this of course is the
General State of criminality all over
California homelessness drug use
everything else and where is the
epicenter of that if Cali's the
epicenter of craziness in America
whereas the epicenter in Cali well of
course it's San Francisco and now in San
Francisco Westfield Mall most of you
have been to a Westfield Mall they're
all over the country the nicest malls
that we have all over America are
usually Westfield malls well Westfield
Mall in San Francisco I believe it is
closed as of yesterday
once a crown jewel for retail shopping
tonight the Westfield San Francisco
Center is pulling the plug on its famed
downtown mall the stunning decision to
walk away comes as the city struggles
with homelessness an open-air drug
market and the perception of crime
did you catch that at the end local news
it's the perception of crime there's a
broken window it's the perception of
crime do you know that people in San
Francisco and around San Francisco area
it's also Oakland and some of the areas
around there people don't leave bags in
their cars anymore because people if
they see a bag in the car they just
break the window and they steal what's
inside there are literally people I've
seen this repeatedly and I've read about
it there are people now in San Francisco
area who when they get out of their car
if they have to park on the street
sometimes they put the windows down with
nothing else in their car because they
they're going on the assumption that all
right these these petty crime people
they don't know how to steal a car right
they don't know how to hot wire a car so
they'll leave the car although they
might take a dump in it but but they'll
that at least they won't break the
windows then to see you know because
they'll see that there's nothing in
there that is the level of what is going
on in San Francisco so I wanted to show
you so as we were putting this together
I was like you know it's it sometimes it
feels a little heavy-handed when you
show this this endless State of Decay in
San Francisco but I want to show you
this video we're going to play it we
took the audio out because there was a
copyright issue because there was a song
playing over it but we can throw to it
and I'll just talk over it this is a
video there's an account that runs
basically uh it's a guy who lives in San
Francisco area who just walks around and
and shows you these These are sprawling
parts of the city so this is not all
just in one area I mean look at look at
this person
this is what's going on in San Francisco
this is the progressive what they would
say is the progressive Utopia but how
much closer to a dystopia this is and
I'm not being heavy-handed when we're
showing you this this is all over San
Francisco people that literally look
like they potentially are dead and and
certainly soon will be dead uh there are
there are very few I mean and trust me
there's there's hundreds of those videos
and it's and it's never stopping there
it's never stopping there but again
these are why is this happening in
places where it's Democrats are in
charge progressives are in charge right
there is a reason because they get
basically everything wrong and then they
blame you for it and then guys like
Gavin Newsom uh get Democrat privilege
right they get to succeed and further
their career and political Ambitions and
go from mayor to governor and
undoubtedly he wants to become president
but ladies and gentlemen there is light
at the end of the tunnel our voices our
actions
our beliefs our philosophies if we put
them into play we actually can make
change we really can we can get rid of
their woke agenda we can get rid of the
corporate ESG agenda when they see the
bottom line ain't working anymore uh and
here is some video from CNN it is
officially true Bud Light is no longer
America's number one beer
so this morning after two decades a new
top selling beer in the U.S Mexican
lager Modelo Especial was the top
selling beer last month overthrowing Bud
Light there are a couple things at play
here including flat out changing taste
but also the backlash from a social
media post by transgender influencer
Dylan Mulvaney right right it was first
off before that thing before the boycott
the cost of the billions it was just
people's tastes were changing suddenly
people realized you know I don't like
drinking this lukewarm piss
oh I finally came around on it no it was
all because of the boycott obviously now
interestingly Modelo which originally
was a Mexican beer is actually owned by
the same company Anheuser-Busch inbev
which is the parent company of Bud Light
also owns Modelo now will people
eventually boycott Modelo would that be
just or anything else like I don't think
because of the decision basically of a
couple idiotic people over at Bud Light
like we should be taking out everybody I
just think that's an interesting thing a
little piece of context within the wider
world of of how Corporate America seems
to work but the point of all of this is
get your children and your families out
of California really like imagine
imagine just imagine guys you have your
kid going to school and one day the
police the authorities whatever it is
show up at your door because they're
going to take your kid away and you will
have had ample time to get out so you
you just must get out and it is never
going to stop and that's with that
whether it's whether it's going after
your kids whether it's literally burning
down your city with crack addicts
everywhere or anything else there are
better ways guys there are moved to some
red States live in places with Law and
Order where people know basic biology
and basic reality and basic math and the
rest of it that is the opportunity we
are going to get to the Reuben
report.locals.com Community Q a in just
a moment and I assume we have plenty of
new sign ups so if you want to get some
new questions in feel free before we do
let me talk to you guys about manscape
real quick guys Father's Day is right
around the corner my first Father's Day
and if you haven't got your dad anything
yet don't worry that's where the
sponsors of today's show manscaped come
in you and I both know he needs some
serious grooming in his life so grab
your dad the performance package 4.0 and
he'll thank you for helping him tame his
Beast imagine surprising your dad with a
sleek well-designed and optimized
grooming kit that says your balls will
thank you on the box their fourth
generation trimmer features a Cutting
Edge ceramic blade to reduce groom
looming accidents thanks to their
Advanced Skin safe technology you might
ask how is this lawnmower 4.0 different
from other trimmers well this upgraded
trimmer includes a multi-function on off
switch that can engage a travel lock
this is a great feature if your father
yourself do a lot of traveling it also
gives you the ability to turn the 4000k
LED spotlight on and off when needed for
more precise shave you can now shave
your balls in the dark the lawnmower 4.0
even though I don't know why you would
be doing that like get to somewhere
where there's some light for God's sake
step outside if you have to but
nonetheless it's a nice feature the
lawnmower 4.0 even allows you to
customize your trim through additional
guard lengths with the sizes of one
point to four have you ever seen a nose
Bush sticking out of your dad's nose
well the weed whacker 2.0 knows it ear
and hair and trimmer is the best nose
hair trimmer on the market and the
perfect gift for your pops they also
have a other amazing products like
cologne crop mop ball wipes crop reviver
ball tone and crop preserver ball
deodorant get your dad a gift you know
they will use its win-win situation for
both mom and dad go to manscape.com and
use code day for 20 off and free
shipping that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
Dave and the real question again it just
begs the question like why would you be
shaving your balls in the dark
I don't know but now you can so there
you go all right let's get to a little
Reuben
report.locals.com Community Q a uh Aaron
says uh it is hurricane season and while
a lot of people just ride them out at
home when you have kids the calculus is
different what is your plan if Miami is
in the path of an anticipated biggie yes
so we are in hurricane season right now
basically starts June goes really I
think technically uh I think till the
beginning of October so it's it's really
like a four month period obviously last
year in Florida we had an unbelievably
horrific hurricane which hit the other
coast Miami where we are southeast coast
that's the Southwest coast came in on
the Gulf side hurricane Ian and they're
still dealing with uh The Fallout from
that I mean I I've been to Sanibel
Island over there I mean it's still it's
just a mess Fort Myers Beach but they're
building back incredibly fast but like
this was biblical biblical basically
category five that just sat on the coast
so yes we are here in Miami I mean look
our house is extremely well built all
you know cinder blocks cement all that
stuff one of the first things that I did
I actually did it about two weeks before
uh hurricane Ian hit because we we knew
that some hurricanes were were coming as
they say uh we have a whole house
generator here which was not cheap but
you know Propane fuel generator
um we have we've discussed like some
places that we would go to if we really
had to get out uh you know we're not on
the water here my house is not on the
water obviously you can get flooding
Inland
um but you know we would just do do the
best we can and we have plenty of
supplies and uh and food for the babies
most importantly and we've got a water
filter a whole house water filter
actually and all that stuff and uh it's
just part of of living in this part of
the world but they say I think if I'm
not mistaken they say the Miami area
Southeast Florida gets a major hurricane
basically once every eight years so
every eight years you're gonna get
something that's really gonna
you know not just a couple days of
serious rain and some flooding but like
really do some damage but it's just part
of being here and uh and I would say
it's a fair trade-off actually uh Leela
says uh Sam Harris said that Biden isn't
worse than Trump honestly how much taxes
were used to pay for this public
perversion of Biden and his gang he's
got to go um I didn't hear Sam say that
specifically but it didn't it doesn't
surprise me it's sort of in line with
where Sam's been at with things it's
kind of disappointing I mean I just
think empirically like if you just
especially if you take the the part of
trump that was purely the you know the
front end of Trump's presidency
pre-covered right pre-covet and then and
then you know we can all discuss the
covid stuff but pre-covered the country
was on fire in the good sense not fire
like burning down cities our economy was
doing well we were signing Middle East
peace deals there was less crime on the
street we all know the lowest black
unemployment lowest Hispanic all-time
unemployment all of those things things
were really working now did he make
mistakes with covid sure did he not
drain the Deep State Shore did he not
build the wall sure so he it didn't all
turn out perfectly but ABS it's just so
profoundly obvious that as we watched
the wokeness go crazy as we watch
inflation which is now around six
percent and interest rates are over six
percent hours we watch all of this stuff
and our our sort of our general lack of
leadership in the world that countries
are looking around going what is going
on with the United States we know that
they have a mentally compromised
president like where is the leader and
if it's not us it's going to be someone
else and I guess that's a heavy burden
on us but it's just fairly clear to me
that yes we would be in a much better
place if Trump uh was President right
now however I think there's a guy even
better than Trump obviously and that's
DeSantis and we shall see what happens
Snow Baby Says is there a place you
enjoy it as a child or adult you would
love to share with your children someday
provided it still exists by the time
they are old enough to enjoy it too uh
you know there are a bunch of places but
one place that I really really loved
growing up and I grew up in Long Island
uh was the queen science center can you
check is it called the queen science
center and it must still exist my
parents would take us there maybe once
or twice a year we would do some school
trips there over the years and then I'd
occasionally go with aunts and uncles
and you know they'd have like all these
cool like lasers that you could do
things with my I remember my grandma
took us once and they had a laser across
the room and they wanted a volunteer
that had a had a diamond ring my grandma
volunteered and I remember they and I'm
probably like 10 years old or something
and they shot a laser across the room
into her diamond ring and it like
fractiled the laser went all over the
place uh oh it's called something else
now it was the Queens it used to be the
queen's kids science museum it's called
the New York Hall of Science now they
had this giant bubble machine so if you
know if you're a little kid they could
put you in a giant bubble and you could
kind of push against it and all the this
kind of fun cool funky stuff and you
know I've always had this sort of Love
of sci-fi and all that so that was fun
there was another thing I remember as a
kid
they had different uh bags of groceries
that weighed a different amount and it
would depending on which one you picked
up it would say oh this is what a bag of
groceries feels like to a 10 year old
this is what it feels like to a 20 year
old this is what it feels like to an 80
year old and you could really understand
that bodies change and all that kind of
stuff that would be a fun place to take
the kids and I'm sure we've got we must
have a kids science museum somewhere in
Miami uh Kathy says do you think that
pride month has been hurt by the Target
and Bud Light Fiasco will there ever be
a time where we can just when it can
just be a one day parade again yeah I
mean this thing doesn't feel like it can
hold forever this idea of a month of it
I mean look there's nothing
I mean I guess it's official in that the
government sanctions it and it's a month
and they put the freaking crosswalks and
the Annoying Flags everywhere and
everyone doesn't shut up about it and it
just it's just unbearable I mean we're
only halfway through this freaking thing
one day would be fine one day would be
fine you want to have a parade and a
parade to just say hey I'm gay Zippity
doodah
you know like okay great like have a
parade or whatever and that just like
anyone can have a parade for any reason
I'm not for Banning parades have a
parade and that's it but this thing with
this month and again celebrating all of
the things that are that are not to be
celebrated like you don't have you can
be into whatever weird kinky thing
you're into you want to put on a puppy
mask you want to have you know a group
of uh you know I can't even think of
anything at this point like it's just
like yeah you're just shaking your head
no Dave don't say it Dave whatever
you're gonna say you're right like
whatever you want to do do in the
privacy of your own home but this stuff
has just burst forth into the streets
there's kids there all that it's like
enough guys like nobody cares about the
gays anymore and that's the way it
should be and that's what the gays
always wanted so enough for the freaking
month
Conway says Dave
one question no one has asked and I
haven't heard you mention have the boys
started to trying to talk or communicate
yet so Justin is now about nine and a
half months Luke is about seven and a
half months Justin is a freaking this
kid is out of control he is the
Tasmanian devil he has endless energy
he's climbing over everything I think I
mentioned it yesterday he's ripping
wallpaper I'm constantly repasting
wallpaper now he just I have barriers
everywhere I'm basically going through
uh I'm jumping over Hoops to get
anywhere in the house we have fences up
it's just Insanity Luke is just chill
this kid just lays there and he just
looks at you he doesn't care he smiles
at you he looks at you never makes a
peep you know but in terms of talking
and communicating
um there's little you know they're
they're making a lot of sounds kids kind
of Babble
they do all this kind of stuff a lot of
laughing with these guys they're both
big big laughers and I love making them
laugh more than anything else but we're
not at full like Talking Words yet that
we are starting to think we were working
on a little uh sign language with Justin
in particular when he's hungry and
whatever and he doesn't want so he does
shake his head no now or no no no and
he'll do a little of this if he wants
more and we're you know we can't quite
tell if he knows what he's doing but
we're working on that kind of stuff so
okay Dave says Dave my wife is asking
for your thoughts on this French Airline
Fiasco where they are no longer flying
between cities that are under two hours
by train I'm wondering how long until a
California follows so if you haven't
heard about this yeah France is Banning
domestic flights under two hours which
is really really nuts so for a little
context of of how the distance of two
hours on a flight I'm here in Miami
Florida obviously is a very long State
you know north to south very long State
you take about a 45 minute flight 40
minute flight or so to Tallahassee which
is obviously where the it's the capital
of Florida where the governor's mansion
is that would be about a seven hour
drive so so what they're trying to do in
France is they want people to either
drive it or really what they want is
they want these people to be on trains
it's just insane it's it's so in line
with all of the backwards things that
that the world seems to be doing in
honor of the green New Deal and all of
that craziness and of course of course
this nonsense will come to California
now the one Saving Grace there is
California is not very good about
building things they've been trying to
build this train from I think LA to San
Francisco for like 10 years and it's
become a massive boondoggle so maybe
they won't even be able to build it but
yes if there is any policy that is
insane whether it's chopping your kids
genitals offer taking your kids away
from you because you don't want their
genitals dropped off or having something
to do with not having gas stoves or not
being able to drive your car or we're
going to stop people from getting on
planes so you can't fly anymore from say
Los Angeles to Sacramento or whatever
yes California will do it if if that
congressman who we showed you earlier
Wilkes if what he said didn't hit you
like I've been around 11 years guys I
can't take this anymore I know you guys
aren't going to stop I'm moving like
that's what he's saying and I hope
people will take his words to heart and
again I know a lot of you guys who live
in plenty of you live in California
we've done plenty of Cali meetups and
everything else but if you have a child
in California at in school grade child
you must move period you must move I see
no way around it uh Rich says will Dave
change his Off the Grid month to June
next year skip the whole Pride
Shenanigans birthday offline summer slow
news month it's not a bad idea like just
get out of here for Pride you know what
I mean just sit in a dark room shave my
balls that's
you know like what are we doing but that
might be a good idea as I mentioned
actually uh for for off the great August
this year it's a little bit abbreviated
because the first debate is August 23rd
so that is in Milwaukee Wisconsin
obviously I should be at that and Rumble
is the exclusive live streamer of that
thing it's not going to be on YouTube I
mean it's an awesome win for rumble and
for free speech online and everything
else so we'll be doing a big post game
show I'll be interviewing some of the
candidates beforehand we're still
figuring all that out so I will come
back on the grid that day we'll do a
live show that morning from Milwaukee
hopefully from the the venue itself I
don't know what menu it's at yet uh and
then we'll do a show during and after
the debate as well but yeah getting off
the grid for pride month next year that
actually sounds unbelievably refreshing
um cam says how do you feel about the
tech companies who gather data on U.S
users providing or selling that data to
the government shouldn't we demand tech
companies pay us for the data we've been
looking into the this all wrong I think
yeah of course you're right of course
you're right about that but you know
look one of the things that we've all
done
handed us this thing 20 years ago and we
didn't even know what the hell we were
signing up for how many times even today
knowing everything that we all know
about big Tech you download an app and
you got to go through the you know you
just have to slide through and the pages
of pages of pages of we're going to do
this that the other thing all the rules
and regulations and you just click
accept and you have no idea what you
just clicked you have no oh we can
actually look at your data from other
apps when you're opening our app we can
monitor you all the time we can figure
out where you are you have no idea and
we all do this we all do this there are
very few of us that have a attorney on
retainer so that every time you download
an app you could be like Bob Bob are
they uh are they going to be tracking me
it's just nuts Connor what was the game
that I told you I actually I haven't
played a video game in forever but I
kept seeing ads on Instagram for what
was it not game a game of war zone or
what the hell was it with the guy who's
just running around shooting all the
zombies and then you can like jump on
something and then you have two soldiers
what was it Age of Empires or something
do you not remember that
you just said three games that are all
games I said three games that are all
anyway there was some game that I kept
seeing an ad for on Instagram and it
looked kind of fun like you're just
shooting zombies kind of mindless I was
like if I have a minute here or there or
whatever maybe I would try to play it I
downloaded it and then I literally saw
the thing and it was like uh this at
this app will track you it will look it
I think it said something to the effect
of it will be downloading your other
app's data and I was like no no and I
just deleted it so we just unfortunately
the government Ain't Gonna Save you you
got to figure out a way to save yourself
and that that's just how it is but it's
also why the way we created locals the
way we created locals like we're not
selling your data
um the Creator actually has access to
your email so they can always get
directly in touch with you and we just
felt we would deal with it a little bit
differently Mitchell says how's the
tequila Journey going any fine
highlights so for those of you that may
not remember
I am creating my own tequila there will
be a trip down to Mexico for a couple uh
tastings we're working on the bottle The
Branding uh the name of the tequila
there's a couple things up in the air uh
I had a big meeting about it yesterday
you know it's very complex to do this it
is not easy to do unless you're willing
to pour basically millions and millions
of dollars into it and distribution
centers and everything else I want to do
some small batch stuff first but even
like I have to create a separate company
because liquor licensing is different
and importing from Mexico and you can
only make you know real traditional
tequila can only be made from Mexico
from I think four uh basically four
Geographic areas where they're where
they're growing the Agave Jalisco and a
few others whatever it is so it's
extremely complex but I'm hoping we can
get this thing going by the end of the
year uh Mike says hey Dave how much time
are you willing to spend trying to Red
Pill a lefty before giving up that's a
good question after that California
legislator suggested using the power of
the government to force parents in
allowing their children to get sex
changes how can someone like Bill Maher
still rubber stamp the Democrat Party
well on the Bill Maher front I am
working on Bill we uh I think we're
going to do this probably the next month
or so where I will interview him I am
going to I can't believe it and I'd like
to apologize to my team in advance guys
we're going to La and we're going to
interview Bill Maher I think we're going
to do it at the club random Studio
nothing off the table uh you know right
now did you guys even know this uh
there's a massive writer strike in La so
the late night shows are not on right
now I guess Colbert and uh who else who
else is out there Kimmel and Bill Maher
and a few of the other guys their shows
are not on right now I don't think
anyone cares I didn't even know about it
apparently it's been going on for like
two or three weeks I didn't even know
about it do you think anyone's like oh
my God where's Colbert I think these
writers are really screwing themselves
uh by doing this because nobody's
watching these shows like who cares
about these hacks in any event uh bill
is still doing his podcast so we're
we're working on that and that is the
type of question I would ask him right
uh I did get into it last time with him
about how much better Florida was on
covid than California and he
acknowledged it and he also acknowledged
that that might be I think I think what
he said was that would be the one thing
if they force him on another vaccine he
did take one at least one that that
would be the one thing that would get
him to move uh you know bill has a
certain
luxury you know people talk about luxury
beliefs the guy's 67 years old he's
probably worth 100 million dollars I
like Bill a lot so this is this is
actually not knocking him
um but he has a certain lifestyle that
you don't have to worry about a lot of
what's going on with the crime and
everything else if you have security
guards and you live in a very secure
area and you don't have kids who might
be getting indoctrinated and everything
else it can be sort of intellectual to
you not in your heart and that's why I'm
saying so clearly to those of you that
have kids in California especially in
the schools you gotta leave you really
have to leave the state is telling you
there is a situation in which we might
take your kids away you got to go uh but
anyway I will I will discuss that with
Bill because look as we get closer to
this 24 thing let's say DeSantis is
Bill's never going to vote for Trump but
let's say DeSantis is the nominee it
really would be worth getting into it
with marfer however many hours it takes
why is it that you would support someone
like Biden who's ushered in all the woke
stuff that you hate who has destroyed
the economy who has just all of the
stuff that you guys get all the stuff
versus this guy you got to tell me now I
know he wouldn't be there on abortion
with him I think he'd probably figure
out some climate things to talk about
which I just think are misguided but
let's have that conversation Maine says
when you and David got married who was
the what was the who was the first
restaurant to oh this is funny sorry let
me read this correctly when you and
David got married who was the first
restaurant to kick you two out serious
question not a joke you're not going to
believe this guys despite being gay
married and sometimes having dinner
occasionally with the dude out in public
I've never been kicked out of a
restaurant although I almost got kicked
out of a restaurant not with another gay
person one night in New York this is
about a year ago this is the last time I
did Gutfeld so you can figure out what
the date was on this but it's within the
year I took Phoenix and Connor to Del
Frisco's Restaurant Del Frisco's
Steakhouse I'm sure many of you have
been there there's one in Midtown it's
it's some that's where my bachelor party
was I've that's where I usually did like
nice dinners over the years it's right
next to Fox so I usually end up there
after doing some Fox hits so I took
Phoenix and Connor there and we met my
friend Bob and my friend Bob was a great
comic back in the day he's an actor now
does some other stuff really one of the
funniest guys I've ever met in my life
and I said to Bob before dinner we're
walking upstairs and I said Bob you know
I told Phoenix and Connor that you're
the funniest guy I know so you really
got to bring it tonight anyway tequila
beer drinks Manhattans it's happening
hours and hours everyone's getting drunk
Bob's putting on a show and he's I mean
people are looking at us he's he's
yelling and screaming like it's getting
out of control and at one point he said
something
he was saying something about salt and
pepper hair and he's like you know
people with salt and pepper hair and he
took the salt shaker and he took the
pepper shaker and he started pouring him
on his head this is a very fancy
restaurant everyone's in suits there and
then he threw the salt Jager
and then security came up to us and they
got to remember like this is my this is
I'm known there like I love this place
and they were like okay you guys are
gonna get going now and uh and then
somehow we ended up at another bar we
ended up at an Irish bar and it just
continued so I don't know that we were
technically kicked out but they
encouraged us to wrap it up but that was
with all straight people uh I've never
been kicked out of a place how would
they even know you go to Waffle House
you guys gay
that's an awful lot of syrup you're
using
doesn't even make sense Barb says how
can we stop this insane path we are
treading on I feel defeated the bidens
Clinton's Obamas getting away with
crimes that are so criminal they should
all be in prison but we have the FBI and
doj covering up from all look I'm with
you uh it's look when I try to do the
show every day what am I always working
with for you guys and and for me to be
able to do it in a positive way there's
a lot of craziness I can't deny all the
craziness the weaponization of
government the wokes of everything else
but then I try to show you that there
are people that are doing things right
there are people fighting positively
there are answers around the corner
there's places you can move all of that
stuff
um but if the if the news is depressing
you actually every day like really
depressing you I would recommend tuning
out a little bit and even if that meant
tuning out of this a little bit I hope I
I think that people watch this to get a
nice dose of news and and laugh a little
bit and everything else but if it can
become too much for everybody right I
mean it's partly why I started doing Off
the Grid which is one of the things that
I think kept me sane over these last six
or so crazy years right
um
but look the weaponization of government
is a massive problem but what do you do
well you know what you could do imagine
this what if we voted in a guy who has
an unbelievable track record of
accomplishing everything he has set out
to do who can clearly lay out what the
problems are who has surrounded himself
with highly competent staff and who is
telling us that from day one I am going
to go in and I am going to deal with
these three letter agencies and I'm
going to get wokeness out of our
institutions and all of those things you
know who that guy is right like that's
Ron DeSantis and there's every reason to
think he can do it the question with
Trump is do you think he can actually
let's say he could become president he
gets through all of this stuff
could he actually do it could He
surround himself with the right people
he's having trouble getting lawyers
right now a couple of his lawyers just
quit this is what happens unfortunately
if you turn on everybody that's ever
worked with you if you go off on Kaylee
mcinany who is the absolute gold
standard All-Star of your Administration
and you go off on her well then other
people are kind of like
you know I do like a lot of things about
Trump and he helped red pill me and I
get it and I don't like the
administrative State and all that but do
I want to work with him do I want to be
fired by him and then have the mob turn
on me because he turned on me and
everything else and I think that's the
problem so I do think there is some
level of a political answer here I think
that goes through to Santa's uh the
Eurasian says to expound on my Matrix
1999 question do you think young people
of today would choose the red pill I.E
reality over getting to lay around all
day in a hot tub of warm goo with free
internet and all they had to do is trust
the robots I.E the government that would
take care of them so if you have not
seen The Matrix you just laid it out
quite nicely and I always talk about the
Matrix because the idea of the Matrix is
that we are carbon bodies will become
the batteries for the digital world the
more time
that we spend not only on this think
about how many of us spend probably more
than half of our day literally over 12
hours a day staring into this thing
doing things on this thing right and I
can be guilty of it too right
but once they strap that onto your face
and now you live in this digital world
and you don't have to take care of your
body as much you just have to keep it
alive because in that world you're you
know whatever you want to be you want to
be a dragon you want to be a dog you
want to be a muscle-bound he-man
whatever you want to be that's what you
can be in that world Conor's looking at
me like I can do that I can do that let
me get in there
but then you just become the battery
right they still need you as the battery
the engine for the thing the ideas of
the thing that's what they need humans
for it's it's a really uh well it's
quite a dystopian and in many ways very
scary concept right but that seems to be
where they want to push us now they will
not go there
um I have no doubt that Mark Zuckerberg
is not giving his kids all of the
devices he wants everyone else's kids to
be on Bill Gates's kids probably did not
grow up with all of this stuff right
they will still eat their foie gras they
will still eat all of their fancy foods
and their meats while you will eat
digital food and in real life you'll be
drinking pink slime out of the gooey bed
you're in for those of you that are not
sci-fi people this may all sound kind of
nuts but just trust me we're ballparking
it here it's kind of happening as for
your question of whether people would
choose the red pill or not most people
will not choose the red pill I think I
think everything that's happened over
these last couple years uh has proven it
right most people when given that choice
when when
um what's his name when Morpheus when
Morpheus shows Neo you want to take the
red pill and know what's up or you want
to take the blue pill and go back to
sleep have your comfortable life but
never know what the truth is most people
confronted with that they're going to go
with the blue pill that's just how it is
one of the great scenes maybe the best
scene in all of the Matrix is I think
his name is cipher he's one of the guys
that's working with Neo so he's like
thought of you know he's a good guy in
the movie but then the machine guys come
to him and they basically cut him a deal
and they're like hey if you give us Neo
we'll give you the blue pill like he
just wants the blue pill at that point
he wants to not know the truth because
the truth is scary right he doesn't want
that anymore he just wants to eat his
he's sitting there at a restaurant he's
like I just want to eat my steak and not
know what is going on and I think a lot
of people are like that and that that
really the mainstream media has preyed
on that corporate press everything else
James says I would like to ask you a
comment uh ask you to comment on the
California train project from LA to San
Francisco oh I mentioned this before
it's been proven to be a boondoggle
Quagmire and it represents the ultimate
in virtue signaling and feel good
programs as a former California resident
you have good insight into why they
continue this project Phoenix can you
Google how much have they put into this
crazy train project from LA to San
Francisco this was another
big project that Gavin Newsom pushed
through I think it's hundreds of
millions of dollars it might even be
like two billion dollars if I'm not
mistaken just to get from LA to San
Francisco uh which by the way right now
you can take that flight it's about a 45
minute flight but to reference an
earlier question eventually they will
get rid of that too
um the real answer to your question is
everything that goes on in California
particularly is a giant grift it has
become a one-party state that cannot
move much there aren't enough good
people there unfortunately enough woke
well not woke enough awake people to
turn this thing around it's sort of like
what's happening to New York City it is
hard to believe what's going on in New
York City but where are the old school
New Yorkers who can't take it anymore
you know the when you think of like the
stereotypical New Yorker from way back
when well most of them aged out many of
them moved down to Florida there aren't
enough good people there to fight the
fight anymore so it will continue that
dissent California will as well are you
sure the numbers you're giving me are
right
Phoenix is telling me this thing right
now is up to this this train okay from
San Francisco to Los Angeles
35 billion dollars right now it was
supposed to be 22 billion so when you
hear numbers like that what you have to
think is where is the money actually
going
where is it actually going and what
happens and the reason it just the
machine never stops is all sorts of
people are paid off you get incompetent
people who are paid off to do this or
that people who can't do projects
properly you then because you now are a
state that also believes in equity you
hire people who are not even competent
the project is now supposed to be
completed by 2030 when was it the
original timeline on that thing
yeah so it was supposed to be completed
by 25. it's now over budget by about 8
billion was that eight billion dollars
like
it's such a perfect example show me
something that's working in California
show me a place that people in
California are like oh it's working
there it's flourishing there things are
great there
it's not just San Francisco you should
be afraid of go to Santa Monica which
was the most beautiful place in all of
Los Angeles right Los Angeles area
Ventura right you go to uh Venice
Venice used to be awesome right Venice
was like the dream of the world this
awesome Beach town and it was just so
cool and there were all these hippies
and it was fun and great food and music
and there was Muscle Beach and Hulk
Hogan and all and Arnold Schwarzenegger
and all of this stuff
and it's an absolute disgusting disaster
ah we're getting some other information
there is a high-speed rail right now
being built in Florida which will go
from Miami to Orlando which my guess is
that's uh probably a little bit less
than the distance Miami to Orlando
that's a what about a four hour drive
and LA to San Francisco is probably
what's LA to San Francisco on a drive
that's probably about six hours six
seven hours so it's not that much
shorter you know ballpark same uh
Miami's Miami to Orlando High-Speed Rail
in Florida
5.6 billion dollars it'll be done next
year and then from Orlando they're going
to take you to Tampa even further north
into the West
so the proof is in the pudding we can do
things right here they cannot do things
right over there you got to decide where
you want to live you want to live in a
place that has good infrastructure that
spends money appropriately that doesn't
tax you to high hell and also doesn't
kidnap your kids pretty good the tickets
are going to cost 80 bucks that's that's
actually awesome to go from Miami to
Orlando 80 bucks and then from there you
could go to Tampa I mean basically
you're traversing the whole state at
that point it's nice to live in a
functional Place guys if you haven't
joined us yet join us at
reubenreport.locals.com quick reminder
if you join for the next three days
through the weekend not only do you get
annually if you subscribe annually you
get two months free you also get a
Reuben report shirt you might get the
Miami shirt you might get the standard
Ruben report shirt somebody gets the
Willy Wonka golden ticket signed at
there's some other images I think we are
now releasing Diamond badges on locals
if you have been a subscriber for over a
year you now get a diamond badge next to
your name Sean that you've been showing
support nice little perk that we're
doing over there so uh good things are
happening guys uh and we're we're
enjoying all the interaction on the on
the community and look as big Tech
continues to melt down we will just keep
building things as I said what we did on
Rumble yesterday this Andrew taped 450
000 concurrent live streamer thing off
Amazon AWS Technologies absolutely
incredible and it is just the beginning
we've got a cold close for you uh you
might might recognize this elderly man
pretending to be president and then
we'll take some more questions and
comments on the other side
ciao
's with you hello
I'm Jill Biden's husband
[Music]